bonjour jean de gliniasty merci d'être
avec nous ce soir sur arte france qu'est
ce qu'il faut retenir de ces discussions
entre russes américains européens à
genève tout d'abord lundi puis à
bruxelles toujours en début de semaine
et maintenant à vienne en autriche
alors tout d'abord c'est une véritable
pyramide c'est à dire que l'on commence
par le négociateur c'est à dire les
états unis ensuite on associe l'europe
via l'otan puisque en fait l'europe n'a
pas d'existence diplomatique
suffisamment fort pour être un
interlocuteur crédible pour les ruses et
puis enfin on associe les lobes l'europe
élargie dans le cadre de l'ol puisque ça
concerne la sécurité de l'ensemble de
l'europe donc déjà il ya une
construction diplomatique parfaitement
cohérente qui a été opéré la deuxième
chose c'est que quand on écoute que
l'ambassadeur de russie à l'océan on
voit très bien qu'il ya trois problèmes
trois problèmes dans le projet de traité
que les russes ont ont proposé
un un problème qui touche une question
de principe l'élargissement de l'otan un
problème qui touche la réactivation des
clauses de sécurité concernant les
armements conventionnels
donc pas de manoeuvres sans prévenir pas
de manoeuvre trop preuve ce genre de
choses et un volet qui touchent les
forces nucléaires intermédiaires les
volets 2 et 3 forces conventionnelles et
forces nucléaires étaient autrefois
couverte par des traités effectivement
si notamment qui a été supprimé voilà
donc l'un a été dénoncée par les forces
du des intermédiaires dénoncé par les
états unis et de traiter 10 f cfa sur
les forces conventionnelles et charles
ix et les canons tout ça est tombé un
petit peu en désuétude les russes ayant
voulu un changement lié à au passage de
l'est à l'ouest d'une partie des pays de
l'ancien bloc soviétique et ses
changements ayant pu être négocié alors
on voit très bien que pour les
américains les partis deux ou trois sont
non négociables
ça dépend où m curseur la vraie
difficulté c'est évidemment la partie
numéro un qui est une question de
principe pour le temps puisque l'otan
selon la fameuse politique des portes
ouvertes estime que lorsqu'un pays de
rejoindre l'otan et des libres de le
faire il reste quand même la question à
poser de savoir si le temps accepte ou
pas ça on n'en parle pas trop mais il
l'a dit mir poutine exige publiquement
que les occidentaux ont renoncé à leur
expansionnisme militaire en europe de
l'est aux portes de la russie qui craint
pour sa sécurité du coup
je crains que à l'état brut comme ça ce
ne soit pas réaliste en revanche il y a
sans aucun doute des moyens de donner
des garanties
indirecte de faire des choses c'est
l'objet de la négociation à mon sens la
négociation politique elle est là et
c'est pas parce que de nouvelles de
nouveaux rendez vous n'ont pas été pris
au sommet que le dialogue ne continue
pas dans ce domaine bien de
négociations la russie a dit aujourd'hui
ne pas avoir d'utilité à de nouveaux
pourparlers avec l'occident qu'est ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est le vice
ministre des affaires étrangères sergueï
riabkov qui l'a dit tout à l'heure
est-ce que les négociations aient ce
qu'elles sont au point mort du coup
sachant également que des sanctions
américaines contre le président russe en
cas d'agression de l'ukraine je cite
franchir est une limite
écouter avant tout ce genre de
négociations il ya toujours une période
de roulement de tambour un vous souvenez
que la russie elle même avait il ya à
peine quinze jours dit que son projet de
traité n'était pas négociable qu'il
était à prendre ou à laisser dans la
réalité on peut on en a commencé en
disputer de même les etats-unis ont dit
il y aura des sanctions terrible contre
la russie si elle envahit du cred donc
c'est normal qu'on fasse monter la
pression une négociation de ce type
c'est une négociation longue il a fallu
plus de trois ans presque quatre ans
pour négocier les accords d'helsinki
les accords sur les forces
conventionnelles en europe il a fallu
des années il avait d'ailleurs un accord
antérieur lem bfmp ça les accords sur le
sur les forces nucléaires intermédiaire
n'a aussi un prix de 2 3 ans donc si on
doit renégocier la sécurité en europe
c'est pas une affaire qui se fait du
jour au lendemain c'est un long
processus avec des montées de tension
des roulements de tambour comme je
disais et des jeux de négociations mais
il est clair on est contré enfin on peut
espérer raisonnablement qu'on est entré
dans un processus
justement quel accord est ce qu'on peut
espérer
qu'elle accorde au pluriel
écoutez
l'idéal serait de trouver de retrouver
un accord de type forces nucléaires
intermédiaires qui interdisent le
déploiement de forces nucléaires au-delà
ou de sape du certaine portée en europe
de retrouver en gros le traité asséné un
peu perfectionner ensuite l'idéal serait
de réactiver le traité sur les forces
conventionnelles en europe pour éviter
les manoeuvres les mouvements trop qui
peuvent inquiéter de part et d'autre de
la frontière et l'idéal serait de
trouver une formule qui sent
qu'au mondial remettre en cause le libre
choix des peuples
permettent pendant un temps peut-être de
mettre un peu ce qui s'est passé dé
facto pour l'ukraine un petit peu
congélateur l'idée d'une expansion de de
l'otan sans renoncer bien sûr aux
principes ça serait pas idéal
en ce moment est ce qu'on vit une
nouvelle guerre froide puisque
chacun semble camper sur ses positions
oui incontestablement
il ya un an ou deux on aurait pu dire
encore que les les dialogues ne sont pas
rendus là ils viennent de reprend donc
en fait c'est une nouvelle guerre froide
mais avec ce qui risque avait de positif
la guerre froide avant nous étions dans
une guerre froide sans dialogue sans
filet de sécurité au dessus de l'europe
etc là nous sommes montrés dans un
processus qui est d'ailleurs
caractéristiques de la guerre froide
c'est à dire à la froid allez-vous à la
fois ce que j'appelle les roulements de
tambour à la fois les démonstrations de
force et en même temps une négociation
parce qu'il ya des enjeux de sécurité
réelle merci jean de gliniasty d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes le directeur de recherche à
l'iris institut des relations
internationales et stratégiques et puis
vous êtes également l'auteur du livre
petite histoire des relations
franco-russes centre géopolitique et
idéologie aux éditions l'inventaire